so this is a new class pretty excited
about it love endgames love talking to
students about in games and how many of
you have been to an in-game class here
before ok excellent so I'm sure
everybody does different things today
we're going to look at a game from the
biggest tournament going on right now
anybody know what that is Tata Steel is
going alone and who's playing in it
anybody knows some really top players
that are playing in it yeah mark magnus
carlsen is playing it and he is winning
right now but today we're going to take
a look at another game that's going on
about tournament a Maxine Bashir lagrave
does anybody recognize that name yeah he
was also here playing in the same field
cop in August so not too long ago and
holy fun anybody know anything about her
tell me a little bit about holly pond
somebody yes yes and she is the
top-rated woman active right now in the
world since judit polgár recently
announced her retirement and she is a
very high rated and now she is starting
to get invitations to these lead events
like Tata Steel chess which was kind of
similar when judit was playing actively
she was always invited to these top
events so it's nice to see how also
getting invited to such elite
tournaments so in this game it's not yet
in then game but it'll be an end game
pretty soon spoiler alert unfortunately
you know it's going to be an end game
because it's an endgame class but one
thing that I think is most important
about any games for four players is when
do you want to get into an end game and
understanding how high the stakes are
when your opponent offers you a trade of
Queens which usually leads to an end
game now technically the definition of
the neg game is not whether or not
queens are in the board but why least
this is what I was taught
and I think it's the most useful
distinction is that an end game is not
about checkmating your opponent but
rather a lot in an end game instead of
trying to checkmate your opponent you're
usually trying to do what first yes
promote pawns yeah it's really simple
and that's why one metric of whether or
not it's an end game or not is is your
king safe in the center of the board if
the answer is yes it's probably an end
game that's why a treat of Queens does
not necessarily guarantee an end game
because there are some positions where
there are no Queens on the board but
there's so many major there's so many
rooks and minor pieces that King safety
is still an issue all right and of
course this is a generalization it
doesn't apply to all situations because
we know there are still some freak
occurrences of a checkmate in the middle
of the board even with only a couple
pieces left but let's take a look at
this position so MBL is playing white
here and what's the first move you might
look at if you're playing white hair one
of the first moves of course we should
always be looking at the forcing moves
in every position so what are some of
the forcing moves in this position yeah
so you would look at the gym H haven't
checked good that is a forcing move and
it needs to be looked at but you don't
really accomplish that much after King
to AJ right unfortunately you just don't
have a lot of firepower and if you could
reverse the place of the Queen and the
bishop life would be quite nice indeed
but unfortunately that's not in the
rules of chess and it would be way too
slow to try to do that black would have
ample ways to stop you from tech meeting
them like just for example even if we
got a bunch of free moves in a row and
we could do and we could do this battery
which by the way is usually a good idea
even in this situation black would be
able to just like stunt it with Bishop
f5 right interfering with the Queen and
the diagonal so I think the conclusion
is that in this
zishan white doesn't really have enough
pieces to realistically you get a
checkmating attack on the king I mean
the only other minor piece besides this
beautiful bishop is this night on a
three and the night of course is nowhere
near being able to attack the can so
usually you just think if you had a dark
squared Bishop for instance it would
maybe be a little bit different but with
just a couple minor pieces it's really
tough in fact as a rule of thumb another
generalization that's not always true if
you're trying to attack an enemy King
usually want two minor pieces because
that often gives you enough firepower
this doesn't really count as two because
this one is not participating in a
potential attack so like for instance
you had a night on 85 you might have
some attacking potential but usually two
is the minimum and more means likely at
that that's a rule of thumb they use a
lot for office when you have an isolated
Queen pond but anyway what other moves
would you look at here besides bishop 87
check and besides Queen 87 check mate
teen it's not allowed yeah
Queen c7 I would definitely look at
that's a nice force you move right
you're attacking the Queen you're
tacking v7 and I'd also probably look at
Queen c5 Quincy seven was actually
played in the game by MBL so this is a
very natural move right like otherwise
why do you have your queen in your work
like this because blacks just going to
play work c8 next move and can test the
file himself right so Queen see Simon is
extremely logical and now the big
question for black is to trade or not to
trade you know try to delay it move your
queen away get some fun things going on
or to just go for the trade immediately
so I'll have you guys take a little
think on this and then we'll we'll vote
and whatever you vote on maxime will do
although the game is already over so
maybe not all right let's vote now so
how many people have you were black if
you were wholly five in this position
would play Queen takes Queen okay how
many people would do something else and
the tread icky queens of the world all
right well you did a by the way I'm
sorry I mixed up I was asking you a
question for a house point of view not
Mac seems but both both very strong
grandmasters I'm sure you were to play
the same move regardless of the question
but how much indeed avoid the trade a
queen so good job but I not so sure
Queen takes c7's a terrible move in fact
I thought there was some really
interesting variations that arose from
at like when you when you first look at
it it doesn't look that great because it
looks like the work is just getting to
this beautiful seventh-ranked square
which is really important in the end
game but then it doesn't seem as bad
because black does have a key move to
kind of Kabul everything together here
what move can black play here hmm where
um well you could not put their visitor
back to see eight but that's not very
desirable in steady up you see six is
much more desirable because now the
bishop defends this but you also don't
you can also retain some defense on the
cfi all right so that's a decent move
and now like suppose white where to play
work you on here to you know make a move
legwork e7 well you could just play
something like work t8 and now suppose
they play rook takes well I don't know
like I'm trying to make a bad move for
white honestly but they say after we're
take ta twerk take c8 now they play like
King f1 so that you can't play Ricky
want Jack right what moves us black hat
here now to be fair this variation is
not forced it's not like uh huh hope you
find what a goddamn this and one against
Maxine but I think it's just a very
funny line somebody's already got it but
let's let me give you the rest of you a
little bit of a chance this is one of
those moves it's like it's not deep it's
just one move but it's very unusual so
it's not always that easy to find
sometimes there's a it's actually a
famous position than Ana's akatsuki
first showed me the many times US
Women's Champion who comes here every
year for the Women's Championship where
it's made in one but it takes most
people several minutes to find it so
sometimes one move can still be hard to
find when I think most people I don't
mean like people who just started to
play chess I mean like everyone so what
is the best move here for black that is
the question do you got it always look
at the four she moves before she moves
is first of all checks and captures but
right after texting captors come moves
it attack bigger pieces right so a
bigger pieces could be a queen there are
no Queens in this position so what's the
next thing exactly so you want to look
at things that attacked biggest pieces
because if they
be defended and you end up when a
material that's a forcing move yes yeah
so 98 is a cool move here and the third
work doesn't have anywhere to go so why
would have to sacrifice the rook for a
bishop and upon so definitely a
reasonable idea at the play Queen takes
e7 instead but this is the kind of stuff
that you have to go through when you're
deciding whether or not to trade Queens
it's a critical decision so you need to
make sure both to think about it in
terms of well words right in chess
sometimes you have to describe your
decisions in words so if I look at this
in turn and I try to think about it in
words I would usually reject that
because I would say well this work is
coming to the seventh rank and I don't
like that it's a very active square so I
don't want to do that my weaknesses are
going to really get pounded on and maybe
I'll lose the game but then if i start
looking at in variations and get a
little bit more concrete i see well hey
wait a second i have some resources here
so you really need to do both things
especially what a critical situation
comes up like a queen trade a queen tree
changes the nature of a chess game so
drastically but you always want to think
longer on that decision when you would
on average in another decision and
that's something that I'd love you ought
to take away from this instead hopefully
the very aggressive move Queen that six
attacking the pawn on h4 and hoping that
she would generate enough counter play
if Maxime took the pond mb 7 which he
did and she did retain some counter play
in fact she won the pawn back on v2
she's also attacking age 4 but this one
now attacks the night on a three so a
maxine wanted to keep his queen activity
while defending this night so if you
play Queen a three I mean started Queen
d6 it also puts pressure on this d Fife
on so now another offering of Queen
trades so now look at it from White's
point of view and tell me yay or nay
so remember the pawn count is now even
but of course white structure was better
to islands as opposed to mom three well
how many people here would trade queens
in this position is why raise your hand
how many how many people would reject
the Queen trade offer and do something
else all right so well in this position
vaccine did decide to trade the Queen's
because partly be did anybody think I
have a reason why in this position yeah
okay good reason right so using all of
these ponds these weaknesses these Swiss
cheese like funds might result in a
advantage from be I'll so i think that's
that's a great reason now MBL played
work to c5 that's pressuring d5 and it's
also giving white the option to pressure
another week pawn right what week pawn
can that work on c5 perhaps target yes
very good okay so Rick a5 is also in the
offing now and in fact that's what
happened so kind of an unusual rook lift
usually when we think about a work lift
we're thinking about check meeting our
opponents King work c 32 g three or a
three this on the other hand is a rook
lift created to attack a week pawn any
of you guys to watch my championship
commentaries know that I like to call
that a rover for work up and over and
here it's a definitely an unusual
execution on it so ho of course trying
to get a little active here because
activity and then games is really
important right so instead of trying to
like well I don't even think she can
defend passively hair but even if she
could in general it's much better to
attack nicéphore does that passively
defend a six well the problem with night
c4 is more tactical than anything if you
play Knights you for
what can I do it's a messy it's a little
messy but it looks like it works out for
me so like if I play work takes d5 here
if you play Knight takes a three I
player takes d7 and I ended up winning
upon right so the only variation you
really have to worry about is black may
be attacking something in this position
like Bishop e6 or something like that
but the problem here is what this is
actually a little this this one is more
messy but it does does look like it
works out for white so what would why do
here yeah we give me and give me an
exact move right now that would be
really good except black has one
potential resource so what would black
try in that position exactly rook takes
e4 and then white would play why
somebody want to finish up that
variation knight Knight takes e4 and
then what do you think about the
position after Bishop takes d5 mm-hmm
and then after night to be 6 that looks
like it's going to be very good for for
white because after what's that after
work to da you have what well what can
you do after that work these sorry you
guys who can't visualize this but
exactly work to do you one looks like
that'll be the end of the story now that
kind of visualization is very important
that's why I didn't move the pieces
because not to annoy people who maybe
lost like forgot what I said or
something but if you can't do that you
got to learn and even if you can you got
to learn to go even deeper the nice
thing about this position it's kind of
like a pawn endgame there's not a lot of
pieces on the board so it makes it
easier to do that visualization but try
doing that when there are twice as many
pieces on the board it becomes more
difficult so that's why you practice in
positions like this and then you get
better so we can take a quick look so
Bishop takes d5 obviously loses work
takes d4 Knight takes e4 Bishop d phi
Knight b6 now work d 8 and after what do
you want there are no more ideas for
black box just going to lose the game
right okay so and that all came from the
excellent question why not night see for
hair so as you can see there's a lot of
tactics and in games so instead of work
c3 was played and now maxine played
another tactical move of work to be one
allowing work takes d3 but then after
work takes b6 it's just so it's going to
be very difficult for block to defending
the pond on a 6 + f6 etc so instead of
ho ho try it on night to a 4 which shows
a couple things it removes the night
from attack and it also attacks the
night on a 3 so this is a really messy
position for an endgame oh and now comes
the really shocked remove
of which I'm sure who actually saw this
move Bishop to b5 it looks really
strange but at the same time in a
position with so few pieces a player of
her level is going to see that and the
idea is that this pawn cannot capture
this Bishop because of the pin and
therefore it gets this Bishop out of
take while attacking this bishop on d7
so just a really cool-looking move so
for instance if instead of dish about 5
which is obviously a better move if
black just tried to take this night on
on a 3 now or you could play Bishop
takes d7 and black would already be in
trouble because now this this night
isn't take and it would seem that the
only way to try to get out of it here is
Knight to c3 right and now let's see
what do you guys think here
pretty messy position right so it looks
like we have to do this right and then
after a night takes a knight takes be
one material is totally equal but both
black's pieces look like they're in some
major trouble I'm just trying to see if
we can actually how much material we can
win here we can definitely win some
material that's for sure are we could
start by just playing like for instance
one very simple variation to win
material is just like we could play
rugby 392 or care and I just pick up the
deep on I'm sure there's something
better than that though but in any case
oh you whole find a much better resource
there play Bishop by five and now a
really sweet move by mvl like just
another really cool move work to be
three getting the work out of take and
also attacking the rook on c3 so ho
checked and then play Knight to c3
getting her own night out of take Bishop
c6 putting pressure on that d5 pawn and
now after work to the eighth Rick c5 and
things are going to start to get clear
up a little bit pretty sound and then I
want to let you guys try playing out
this position actually when things get a
little bit less crazy
so here after night b5 they're still
tactics going on right so she can't he
can't play work takes b5 because the
night on a c4 is hanging so instead
night to III was played and now after
work c5 this is where I'd like to give
you guys a chance to play this out
before we look the rest of the game I
think the plate by the play by maxine
bacio lagrave in this game was quite
extraordinary but i think like one of
the things is it's not if you play over
the game quickly you don't realize quite
how masterful the technique of these
greats are for instance many players
here who you know you got a lot of the
moves correct earlier in the game but
once or once you're confronted with the
position yourself a lot of people in
this position did not play the right
move in which like Maxine continue to
put pressure on on hall I mean the one
thing in this position that's very clear
to know is one minor piece is better
than the other which minor piece is
better in this position night night you
also visit the night is better than the
video here it took a beautiful night
these pawns are in dark squares so they
could become targets later the night has
a lot of nice landing squares like d5
this Bishop is going to have trouble
finding targets and anchors well it's
true that the black does have blacks
bishop doesn't control the view on
square which would usually be a good
thing but the problem is it's going to
be very difficult for you to even
advance the pawn to b4 so if you can't
even advance it to be four then it's
going to be kind of very difficult for
you ever to get it to be one also there
is only one pawn on the side of the
board once this pawn gets eliminated if
it gets eliminated then you'll be left
with just two and it's well known that
on when there's only pawns on one side
of the board that the night is stronger
so even though that hasn't occurred yet
we're kind of starting to get into that
secondly in this position oh no okay his
position the move Knight e5 immediately
just sets up a bunch of strong threats
right 97 Knight takes f6 and black has
to kind of struggle just to hold on here
she played King to h eight kind of
trying to like tactically recover
because after Knight takes f6 she had in
mind worked to e5 and she said should we
get some good counter player but you see
I just think the instinct among players
is too quick to trade we call this trade
itís every player pretty much underneath
the certain level and that level is
quite high under night needs really the
professional level trades too much it's
extremely rare to find a non
professional chess player who trades too
little right the reason is because we
like releasing the tension if you make a
trade you know what your opponent is
going to play and that gets us a sense
of confidence right so there's a lot of
psychological reasons behind it but that
means that you shouldn't never trade but
whenever you're confronted in a position
where your attempted to trade hold back
and make sure you have really good
reasons and that you're considering
other options because I'm not going to
say that white knight might have sure
why you might have some chances for
activity after Knight takes f 5 but
after night to d5 black has very serious
problems right so and you would easily
see 95 if you didn't have the option of
night takes fi so it's almost like the
option of trading is distracting you
from your true goals in the game which
is to win obviously and after work e5f 3
and now after work to e6 another really
nice moment come so this is like a nice
little tactical idea because if we're
takes you six now Bishop takes you six
and this is intake and this isnt ape
right so this can be very problematic
and this I'm sure was hos original idea
once you play King Danny chain but here
a Maxine can do what maximum has a good
move here
I've seen this white yeah
nike 7 interesting I'm a little worried
about the fate of your night on it's a
good idea but I think your night might
be good trapped on f8 like so if Knight
to d7 rook takes d6 night takes f8 King
g7 seems like a problem well maybe you
ever taste beef I there but then Bishop
d3 yeah 94 was played really good move
can't take this night off with the
bishop because then work takes c6 right
and if you play rook takes d6 night
takes d 60 a really cool moves is kind
of getting everything out of take nice
idea this move i love this blockading
move is wonderful because somebody
pointed out earlier that is this pawn
gets going box going to get a lot of
counter play very beautiful move usually
you want the works behind the past pawn
but in this particular position
blockading it in a situation where you
also have this like lateral defense of
your night it's just a really really
nice move you're fixing it on this light
square as well that you can easily
attack it with with a night later so a
really nice technical move and now
maxime continue to play some nice moves
here right g4 is a very typical move in
the end game with the idea that we're
expanding by playing g5 check and it's
going to be difficult for black with
this passive bishop in this passive rook
to kind of contest our ponds coming
forward so she tries to get active here
but it's basically not really enough
game kind of ends really need sweetly to
so actually i think it was resigned here
but i have a couple more moves that i
just wanted to show you guys so now why
is this position so good for right
suppose black plays Bishop d7 what can
white do now okay so Rick takes you're
working a lot hmm what move in
particular there's a there's one move
here that's better than the others yeah
yes g5 we call this a pawn breakthrough
and if you take on g5 now just h6 and
it's impossible to stop this pawn right
so you can't play Bishop b5 to g8 you
can't play Bishop before the king is too
slow so if g five instead black would
have to play king e seven with the idea
that now with pawn takes pawn at least
black and play a lot yeah what do you
think and these black can play King f6
right and now what do you think the best
move in this position is just to finish
it up in style then you want to distract
him with an ie but Essex is not the
right square area 97 works because now
can you 787 you can't get the King back
so the only way for black players move
the bishop and now how do you finish off
hmm 96 is really nice because now King
g8 doesn't work because a lot King GA
fails to what anybody else yes h7 check
setting up that's what you were going to
say to right so after h7 check now King
takes h7 allows what the fork that's
right night to f8 check and the game is
over so really nice technical display by
maxime here and well the main things I
want you to get out of that is a
Titus you know be careful about
overtraining because a lot of times your
advantage in the end game is slim and in
order to press it you need to make sure
to keep your good pieces and stop your
opponent from from trading off their bad
pieces and secondly just something you
always want to keep in mind even though
in this position both options were
reasonable you always want to see when
your opponent's offering you a trade of
Queens think a little bit more than
usual all right because that could
change the entire character of the game
and put it into this class because it's
an endgame class well I'll be here for
another week and a half so I hope to see
some of you guys next week